euh nous avons lancé à la Commission de
la Défense nationale la semaine dernière
un cycle sur les enjeux sécuritaires en
Afrique et avant d'arriver aux
enjeux sécuritaires stricto sensus la
question de nos bases la question des
opérations de maintien de la paix la
question des entreprises de sécurité et
de défense il nous a semblé intéressant
d'avoir un travail pour réfléchir à tout
ce qui pouvait être l'environnement de
de ces enjeux sécuritaires et donc c'est
à ce titre là que je remercie le le
président quecel d'avoir accepté
l'organisation d'une audition conjointe
entre nos deux
commissions dans le cadre de de ce cycle
et je trouve qu'il est extrêmement
intéressant qu'on puisse favoriser
l'interaction entre nos commissions
respectives ces interactions me semblent
d'autant plus importante qu'elle
matérialise la nécessité d'une défense
globale qui a d'une part le fait que not
politique de défense doit être l'affaire
de tous de l'ensemble des des députés
notamment de de cette Assemblée
nationale et et de l'ensemble des des
Français un de nos grands anciens disait
chaque Français doit se sentir
personnellement responsable de de la
défense de de son pays et deuxièmement
que l'ensemble des politiques publiques
contribue de facto à définir la
politique de défense d'un pays et
notamment sa capacité de résilience à à
une crise et pour aborder le thème qui
nous occupera ce matin pendant les 2
heures qui arrivent il va de soit que
les sujets de
financement notamment d'endettement de
souveraineté financière ont un impact
directement on un impact direct pardon
sur l'autonomie stratégique d'un pays et
par conséquent sur sa politique de
défense on a souvent l'habitude de dire
que l'argent est le nerf de la guerre
les enjeux financiers peuvent également
être un levier de puissance on a
beaucoup parlé ces derniers mois de
sanction de de gel d'avoir un enjeu de
renseignement vous connaissez tous
l'existance du service tracf à Bery et
enfin mes chers collègues je pense qu'il
faut avoir tous conscience que nous
sommes dans dans un monde en compétition
en proit parfois une forme de guerre
informationnelle et dans une démocratie
le moyen du faire d'y faire face c'est
également le débat et la transparence et
concernant le le thème d'aujourd'hui
bien entendu on a tous en tête notamment
les questions autour du du Fran CFA qui
ont animé beaucoup des débats hier dans
l'hémicycle dans le cadre du débat 50-1
et je trouve que cette audition est
vraiment l'occasion de reposer les
choses en toute transparence le lien en
tout cas entre souveraineté euh
financière et autonomie stratégique est
d'autant plus prégnant en Afrique dans
un contexte où le ratio d'endettement
moyen en Afrique subsaharienne après que
doublé en 10 ans pour évoquer cette
thématique nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir monsieur pierre-jacquemot
universitaire et ancien ambassadeur en
poste dans plusieurs pays africains
notamment je crois Kenya Ghana
République Démocratique du du Congo vous
pourrez nous éclairer Monsieur Jacques
Moot sur les conséquences géopolitiques
pour les pays africains de leur
endettement on pense naturellement au
rôle de la Chine qui s'est affirmé ces
dernières ces dernières années comme un
créancier majeur des pays africains et à
la dépendance stratégique voire
militaire qui pourrait découler d'une
telle situation nous accueillons
également Monsieur William
Ross chef de service des affaires
multilatéral et du développement à la
direction générale du Trésor pourra
aborder monsieur Ros ou Ros on dit bien
ça l'action de la France quant aux
dettes des pays africain notamment dans
le cadre du Club de Paris qui traite des
opérations de de restructuration et de
dettes souveraines enfin Monsieur Bruno
Cabriac vous êtes directeur adjoint à la
direction générale des statistiques des
études et de l'Internationale à la
Banque de France pour évoquer plus
particulièrement Monsieur Gabriac le
bilan des réformes du Fran CFA depuis
2017 voilà pour ma partie introductive
monsieur le Président cocrel en vous
remerciant à nouveau d'avoir accepté le
principe de cette audition commune je
vous cède la parole bien merci monsieur
le Président de la Commission de la
Défense cher Thomas mes chers collègues
donc on tient ent ce matin une réunion
consacrée à l'Afrique son endettement et
les coopérations monétaires qui relient
des pays de ce continent à la France
conjointement et thomasessilou l' l'a
expliqué avec la commission la défense
sttiale et des forces armées et de ce
point de vue-là je pense effectivement
que c'est une excellente chose je
remercie Monsieur Bruno Cabriac
directeur adjoint de la Banque de France
William Ross chef de service à la
direction du Trésor pierre jacquesm
ancien ambassadeur universitaire pour
leur participation à cet échange comme
ça je je rédite un peu les noms qui
viennent d'être moi ça rentre dans les
têtes je meé jouis de cette occasion que
nous avons de Ten réunion commune avec
la commission de la défense statiale et
d'aborder les sujets majeurs qui
dépassent nos frontières et que nous
n'avions plus abordé en commission des
Finances depuis une audition que nous
avions tenu sous la précédente
législature le 12 février 2020 afin
d'évoquer alors le récent accord de
coopération entre la France et les
États-membres de l'Union économique et
monétaire ouest-aricaine UE MOA donc je
rappelle qu' est composé de la Côte
d'Ivoire Sénégal Burkina Faso Bénin Togo
Niger Mali qui avait été signé le 21
décembre 2019 et qui mettait fin à la
centralisation au Trésor français des
réserves de change de la banque central
des États d'Afrique de l'Ouest et
prévoyait le retrait de la France des
instances de gouvernance nul doute que
nous avons désormais un peu plus de
recul pour analyser les conséquences de
ces changements et du coup je me
permettrai au seuil des audition de
livrer deux interrogations majeur qui
vaudront en fait en réalité aussi deux
questions ma première interrogation est
la suivante les pays occidentaux même
s'ils se donnent l'illusion ou la bonne
conscience de faire tout ce qu'il faut
pour alléger la dette des pays africains
ne se placent-il pas dans un entre deux
finalement ambigu voir hypocrite cette
dette constitue effectivement un facteur
de préoccupation puisqu'elles exposent
ces pays au marché financiers à la
spéculation sur leur dettes publiqu mais
il est regrettable de s'alarmer sur le
niveau des dettes sans envisager leurs
besoins et les moyens nécessaires pour y
répondre alors que je le rappelle pour
chaque pays le poids de la dette
représente en moyenne 57 % du PIB soit
un niveau inférieur à celui prévu par le
traité de mastrich pour adhérer à l'euro
la crise climatique et la bifurcation
écologique viendra viendront
nécessairement alourdir ces dettte selon
un groupe d'experts indépendants créés
sous les gites de l'ONU l'ensemble des
pays en développement à l'exception de
la Chine devront dépenser plus de 2000
milliards de dollars par an d'ici 2030
pour assurer leur développement et
s'engager dans la bifurcation écologique
sans cela les objectifs de l'accord de
Paris ne seront pas
en l'absence de financement
supplémentaire les pays les plus
vulnérables au changement climatique
seront donc incapables de financer leur
adaptation les solutions ne peuvent pas
reposer sur les anciennes logiques
basées sur la croissance éternelle pour
dépasser cette contradiction ne
faudrait-il pas proposer d'augmenter
massivement les financements fléchés
vers les pays africains des économistes
dont Joseph Stiglitz
y Yati gauche pardon avec qui j'ai
échangé récemment à Bruxelles propos
propose d'instaurer une taxe sur les
transactions financières élargies qui
permettrait de lever jusqu'à 400
milliards d'euros par an des ONG donxfam
et l'ORAC plaident pour une taxe sur les
énergies fossiles dont le produit serait
affecté au faible au pays à faible
revenu une taxe sur le transport
maritime est également envisageable et
donc ma deuxième interrogation est la
plus courte la récente réforme du franc
CFA n'est-elle pas en trompeluille dans
la mesure où elle est maintenue où est
maintenu une parité avec l'euro souvent
pénalisante pour les exportations et la
compétitivité des économies à africaine
cette introduction me permettra d'éviter
de reposer des questions après et je
pense que je vous passe ainsi la main
monieur Cabria cross et jacquesem nous
vous
écoutons et donc on m'a dit que vous
aviez un peu modifié l'ordre et que
c'était Monsieur Jacques ma qui
commençait donc Monsieur jacquem Vous
AVEZ LA
PAROLE invitation à prendre la parole
devant vos deux commissions et vous
parler de la situation qui prévut
actuellement en matière économique et
sociale en Afrique et nous sommes
répartis les tâes en en me confiant le
soin de de donner quelques éléments un
peu un peu généraux de cadrage de la
situation actuelle avant d'aborder les
questions de plus spécifiquement de
financement et de gestion de la de la
dette la première considération
importante et encore une fois je parle
de toute l'Afrique qui é d'une très
grande maladresse on a l'habitude de
parler maintenant des Afriques dans la
situation qui prévaut dans 54 ou 55 pays
peut être fort différente donc je me
tiendrai à quelques généralités qu' me
semble pertinente juste cette photo pour
vous montrer des cordons pierreux au
Burkina Faso dans une zone sahélienne
extrêmement rude et montrer la capacité
des paysans à gérer le peu d'eau à la
fin de l'hivernage de de façon à
prolonger les cultures de d'un ou deux
mois
supplémentaires aux alentours du mois
d'octobre et du mois de novembre c'est
une photo que j'ai prise très très
récemment et qui montre cette
ingéniosité fort ancienne qu'on qualifie
aujourd'hui d'agroécologique bien
évidemment ce ce concept n'existait pas
pour répondre à des contraintes
climatiques qui sont absolument
considérables ici vous avez juste une un
aperçu des des processus majeurs de des
i ification d'élévation des niveau des
niveaux de la mer des cyclones des
processus de déforestation euh des
dégradations des zones forestières et
cetera juste si vous regardez la la
grande Île de Madagascar tous les
phénomène climatique se concentre
notamment sur cette île
euh particulièrement particulièrement en
situation de très grande
vulnérabilité la la covid a été gérée
euh d'assez bonne manière par la
majorité des pays africains étant
entendu que le problème a été moins
sanitaire que
économique les entraves à la mobilité
des personnes qui ont été très largement
respecté se sont traduit par toute une
série de de d'effets négatifs en terme
de d'insécurité alimentaire et et
nutritionnelle les éessances ont été
réduits les budgets familiaux ont été
amputés les transferts d'immigrants ont
été moindres alors qu'ils sont
absolument essentiels dans le
financement de la vie économique en
Afrique en tout cas pour un certainombre
de pays euh les importations
alimentaires ont baissé et les et les
prix ont augmenté si vous rajoutez
l'impact de la crise ukrainienne
notamment sur le prix des produits
alimentaires et sur le prix des engrais
vous avez un une
double une double contrainte qui impèait
sur ces pays
euh il y a une
un très gros
problème nutritionnel dans nombreux pays
africains il peut y avoir des des
phénomènes
de de malnutrition par carence
alimentaire et carence en nutriment mais
également des phénomènes importants qui
peuvent se développer dans les villes
des phénomènes d'obésité ce qu'on peut
constater c'est qu'il y a une une assez
forte corrélation spatiale entre
insécurité physique des personnes et
malnutrition bon c'est assez c'est assez
évident mais tous les travaux
cartographiques qu'on peut faire en
juaposant deux cartes cell de la
malnutrition et celle de l'insécurité on
constate qu'il y a un recouvrement
important avec un phénomène qu'on a
étudié en terme de recherche à la suite
d'une publication dans Afrique
contemporaine du monté de la violence
dans les relations entre pasteur et
éleveur la vie pastorale en Afrique
concerne grosso modo 250 millions de
personnes c'est-à-dire 20 % de la
population
africaine je parle de la vie pastorale y
compris la chaîne de valeur qui va
jusqu'au lait la viande le le cuir et
cetera et on se rend compte ici dans une
communauté peul que pratiquement
maintenant tous les pasteurs sur la
bande sahélienne en tout cas mais
également à Madagascar et en partie au
nord de l'Afrique du Sud euh sont armés
pour défendre leur bétail contre les
Vals de bétail on est donc dans une
situation d'insécurité physique
croissante dans la plupart des pays et
un un autre phénomène important qui
évidemment vous intéresse au premier
chef qui est celui du retour des
militaires du retour des coups d'État en
Afrique ces coups d'État étaient
fréquents jusque dans les années
90 qu'il fus réussi ou
manqué et vous voyez que sur la dernière
période 2020 2023 on a assisté en gros
sur les 3 années à 11 coups d'État euh
dont certains ont été réussis que vous
connaissez évidemment la Guinée le Mali
le BurkinaFaso le Niger le Soudan le
Gabon et pour certains on estime que le
chat c'est un quasi coup d'État en tout
cas c'est une transmission non
constitutionnelle du pouvoir qui s'est
faite donc on est dans une situation de
qui de retour de coup d'É
de renversement constitutionnel et plus
largement une un retour à des événements
de de grande violence comme vous pouvez
le voir sur l'année 2023 et euh pour les
premiers mois sur l'année sur l'année
2022 et pour les premiers mois sur
l'année 2023 donc voilà en gros la la la
situation qui prévaut euh d'insécurité
assez généralisé qu'elle soit euh
climatique alimentaire agricole
ou simplement sécuritaire les tendances
lourdes alors on assiste grosso modo à
ce que la Banque mondiale appelle une
croissance à deux vitesses et et on
distingue la Banque mondiale distingue
les pays pauvres en ressources
naturelles et les pays riches en
ressources naturelles et c'est peut-être
un un paradoxe pour vous de constater
que l'impact de la crise associée à la
covid et la crise ukraénienne est plus
forte sur les pays riche en ressources
naturelles ces ressources naturelles
peuvent être aussi bien le pétrole que
un certain nom de minerais et en effet
il y a dans les pays riches en
ressources naturelles un phénomène de
concentration sur l'activité minière ou
l'activité pétrolière ce qu'on appelle
la malédiction des matières premières et
un une réduction de la diversification
des activités et donc une plus grande
vulnérabilité aux impacts euh des chocs
extérieurs notamment les chocs de prix
bien évidemment
donc
la une des solutions que nous devons
appuyer dans notre réflexion sur
l'avenir de l'Afrique la première c'est
certainement promouvoir la
diversification c'est facile à dire il y
a des pays comme le Gabon moi j'ai fait
une mission en
1982 autour de la diversification de
l'activité pétrolière de l'activité
économique au
Gabon pensant à une possible chute des
des ressources pétrolières
et je veux dire aujourd'hui ce ce
rapport que nous avions fait au titre du
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères pourrait être aussi valable
aujourd'hui sur une incapacité à assurer
cette
diversification une chose que vous savez
bien évidemment c'est le poids
démographique futur de l'Afrique ici
vous avez une projection à l'horizon
2050 et la partie je sais pas si le sort
bleu ou plutôt verte sur votre écran
avec à l'horizon 2050 2 milliards
d'habitants pour l'Afrique ce sont des
estimations un peu grossières he les
démographes au-delà de 10 ans prennent
un certain nombre de précautions pour
faire des projection mais en gros vous
voyez quand même que la part la place de
l'Afrique dans la population mondiale va
être importante ce qui se traduit par
excusez-moi elle sort très mal par une
montée de la jeunesse et par un
phénomène important qui est celui de
l'urbanisation euh si vous regardez ce
graphique
vous constatez que l'Afrique qui est en
rouge qui est en bas son son poids
relatif dans la population en as de
travailler dans la population active son
poids relatif augmente dans la
proportion du monde
entier notamment vis-à-vis de la Chine
et de l'Inde et donc potentiellement
l'Afrique offrira une une une offre de
travail une main d'œuvre disponible à
l'échelle de de de l'économie mondiale
de plus en plus importante de l'ordre de
20 % dans les à l'horizon 2050
euh donc le continent va connaître la
plus forte croissance de la population
en â de travailler ce qui oblige les
États à absorber une dizaine de millions
de jeunes chaque année alors que la
capacité du secteur salarié privé
classique est de l'ordre de 3 millions
donc ça veut dire que c'est dans
d'autres activités que celui de
l'activité salariée que la jeunesse
devra trouver une intégration dans ce
qu'on appelle euh très très sobrement le
le secteur le secteur informel euh
expression qui veut tout dire et ne rien
dire bien évidemment les définitions
négatives informels ne sont pas très
riches mais disons en tout cas dans le
secteur non non structuré non fiscalisé
non
enregistré lequel secteur peut être un
secteur dynamique par ailleurs euh et
puis j'en term m sur des des phénomènes
extrêmement importants et qui sont de
nature à changer la donne c'est celui de
l'urbanisation un Africain sur de est
urbain je dirais en fait plus
précisément en africain/ de et
rurbain souvent un Africain est à la
charnière entre le ce qu'on appelle nous
le monde urbain et le monde rural en
particulier dans les dans les villes
intermédiaires dans les villes de 200 ou
300000 habitants vous pouvez avoir voir
dans l'année une activité de type rural
de type agricole et une activité de type
urbain évidemment en fonction des du
calendrier climatique mais quoi qu'il en
soit on arrive à à des à des phénomènes
de métropolisation importantes on le
sait autour du C on le sait autour de
legos on le sait autour de Kinshasa on
le sait autour de d'Abidjan de Dakar
vous arrivez même à des ceintures
urbaines qui vont de Dakar à Yaounde euh
potentiellement importantes avec une
très forte densité donc l'urbanisation
est un
phénomène très très fondamental et qui
ne cesse de
croire et de poser des problèmes
d'organisation et de gestion de la ville
alors cont tenu de ces données les
besoins les besoins financiers sont
considérables peut-être que mes mes
collègues seront plus précis que moi
mais on estime que pour financer la
reprise poste covid il fallait environ
285 milliards de dollars sur le
continent que pour financer les
objectifs du développement durable à
l'horizon 2030 qui est le l'année
l'année de fin du processus des odd il
faut 200 milliards et l'amortissement de
la dette suppose 65 milliards supposé
début 2022 65 milliards mais là on sera
peut-être plus précis dans les dans les
chiffres donc les besoins sont
considérables alors que les les les
besoins de financement sont
considérables alors que euh les les
difficultés sont sont croissantes j'ai
pris pensant que ça serait peut-être
parlant pour vous les nos nos nos
représentant du peuple dans d'un certain
nombre de villes de vous donner une idée
de ce que de ce qu'est le le budget de
la ville de Dakar euh 40 € par habitant
par an comparé au budget de la Ville de
Paris qui euh est de l'ordre de 3600 €
par habitant par an euh vous avez donc
euh une des écarts absolument
considérables qui peuvent exister dans
la gestion dans les financements alloués
à la gestion des des
ville un tout tout petit exemple la
ville de ouagadougu qui compte 1,5
million
d'habitants un budget qui
est à peine deux fois plus important que
celui de la ville de Rodes qui fait
25000 habitants vous voyez
donc la complexité qui se qui se trouve
dans la gestion des
villes donc les les les budgets
nationaux contenus de ce contexte les
budgets nationaux sont sous très très
très forte euh hausse avec une
augmentation de leur niveau
d'endettement une résurgence d'un
problème d'endettement qui avait été en
partie résolu dans au début des années
2000 grâce à un certain nombre de
processus d'annulation ou de report de
dett euh et il y a des situations de
extrêmement dramatiques en terme
d'endettement qui p sur des pays euh
critiques comme l'Angola l'Éthiopie le
Kenya la République démocratique du
Congo alors que les besoins sont
considérable ça c'est une photo qui qui
qui qui est vraie qui pas un montage
d'enfants qui essayent de trouver une
place dans une une classe surchargé et
dans un une situation de déficit de
moyens absolument considérable j'ai
simplement sorti le budget des armées de
trois pays clés actuellement dans la
situation critique au Sahel qui sont le
bur qui là le Mali Niger il y a une
petite interruption sur le Niger parce
qu'il y a petit déficit de données dans
le pays mais vous voyez que il y a une
année charnière qui tourne autour de
2013 où il y a une montée très
importante des des budgets militaires ce
qui est ce qui est intéressant un
collègue chercheur ADIAL a démontré que
plus les budgets militaires augmentent
plus la la la probabilité d'un coup
d'état ou d'un renversement
constitutionnel est importante cette
thèse révèle absolument exact puisque
les budgets du Mali et du Niger n'ont
jamais du du Mali et du Burkina Faso
n'ont jamais été aussi élevé que l'année
l'année du coup
d'État alors je va je vais terminer sur
quelques considérations qui vont
peut-être vous interpeller ou peut-être
mes mes collègues du Trésor de la Banque
de France ne sont peut-être pas tout à
fait d'accord mais
euh je je prétends que l'Afrique a une
grande légitimité à réclamer un soutien
financier du reste du monde d'abord
parce que c'est l'Afrique qui supporte
le plus les externalités négatives de la
mondialisation notamment en terme de
perte de biodiversité en terme
d'expansion des grandes endémies de
réchauffement climatique et elle subit
de plein fouet l'impact de crise comme
celle de de
l'Ukraine
on a l'habitude de dire que l'Afrique
n'est pas émettrice de de CO2 mais en
subit le plus fortement l'impact en gros
c'est c'est cette observation que je
peux faire donc il y a une légitimité à
dire nous sommes dans une situation
extrêmement
pénalisante du point de vue économique
et social mais dans le même temps on
peut dire que l'Afrique joue un rôle
fondamental dans l'équilibre de la
planète et en particulier dans
l'équilibre de sa biodiversité rien le
bassin du
Congo j'ai eu l'honneur de servir
pendant 3 ans à Kinshasa rien que le
bassin du Congo
absorbe l'émission de gaz à effet de
serre de l'ensemble des véhicules de la
planète c'est le deuxième poumon et
peut-être malheureusement si l'Amazone
est très mal gérée deviendra le premier
poumon mondial donc il y a un rôle
absolument éminent que peut jouer en
terme de services environnementaux le
continent
africain qui mérite
compensation et qui mérite rémunération
si on veut que ce patrimoine mondial ce
bien public mondial puisse être
correctement
géré voilà deux deux considérations qui
font que le sur la la scène financière
internationale l'Afrique arrive avec un
certain nombre de d'arguments pour dire
on a besoin d'un traitement particulier
en ce qui concerne le financement de
notre développement et puis enfin et là
c'est là peut-être que je vais être le
plus choquant on pourrait se poser la
question de savoir si l'Afrique n'est
pas créancière finalement du reste du
monde la fuite des capitaux est si
répandue que le continent est devenu un
créancier net plus de sortie flux
d'entrée les flux de sortie sont divers
bien évidemment la fraude fiscale mais
surtout les rapatriments par le biais
des prises internes des des des grands
groupe des multinationales par le
truchement en particulier dans dans le
secteur dans le secteur minier fait
qu'il y a des flux de sortie qui sont
évalués par la cuset qui est la
Commission des Nations Unies
sur le commerce et le développement de
l'ordre de 90 milliards évidemment par
définition c'est des des chiffres
relativement approximatifs on est
souvent dans des fourcettes qui vont de
80 à 120 milliards par an de flux de
sortie je rappelle l'aide publique au
développement sur l'Afrique c'est 40000
Milard
euh alors c'est la plupart du temps des
opérations commerciales des prix de
transaction à l'intérieur des des
groupes des activités criminelles de la
corruption tout ce qu'on veut
euh voyez bon les flux de sortie sont
particulèrement significatif dans
certains pays le Nigéria est bien sûr le
plus désigné pays pétrolier par
excellence l'Afrique du Sud l'Angola le
Congo l'Égypte le Maroc donc contenu de
cette données on peut se poser donc
cette question de savoir si finalement
euh l'effort ne doit pas être aussi
principalement porté sur la gestion de
ces flux de sorti de façon à
endogénéiser intérioriser en quelque
sorte le modèle de financement alors
c'est une interrogation qui est
régulièrement posée par les chefs d'État
africains qui comme vous le savez ont
décidé il y a 2 ans enfin c'est tout un
processus il eu un grand moment qui est
celui-ci à Kigali en 2018 et puis la
mise en œuvre est progressive de de
créer une zone de libreesence à
l'échelle continentale c'est la plus
grande zone de libreesence du
monde
potentiellement avec toute une série de
de d'orientations sur sur les
infrastructure sur l'intégration
commerciale les chaînes de valeur de
production la libre circulation des
personnes l'intégration financière et
macroéconomique voilà en gros voilà en
gros le un premier anorama qui permettra
je l'espère d'aller plus plus plus fin
sur les questions financières mais
peut-être pour terminer je voudrais
juste citer de deux grands auteurs
africains pour dire que pour simplement
rappeler dans quels sont les termes de
la discussion en Afrique par les
Africains eux-mêmes et on assiste
aujourd'hui à une remontée d'un de deux
de deux tendances assez
forte que l'on croyait éteintre depuis
les années 70 c'est la Moné d'une
certaine forme de
souverainisme et puis la monté également
de d'un néo panafricanisme d'une
conscience
africaine et qui se retrouve dans ce
type de phrase fwinsa est un grand
économiste et philosophe
sénégalais qui nous rappelait que
l'Afrique n'a personne à rattraper c'est
c'est très très bien c'est un concept
celui du rattrapage que l'on a hérité de
d'une conception du développement très
très ancienne qui date des années 60
euh c'est à l'Afrique de choisir son son
sentier son cheminement euh et d'autant
que le un autre philosophe important
burkinabé très très connu Joseph kisarbo
nous rappelit que dans la tradition
africaine il faut pas il faut apprendre
à ne pas se cousser sur la Nate des
autres car c'est le plus sûr moyen de se
retrouver par terre donc c'est
simplement pour vous dire quel est le le
le quel est le climat quel est le
intellectuel qui prévoit actuellement
parmi parmi nos collègues africains dans
leurs réflexion sur sur les question de
développement je vous
remercie merci Monsieur jacquesem la
parole est désormais à Monsieur Ros donc
de la DG trésor
oui
pardon merci beaucoup pour cette
invitation messieurs les les présidents
madamees et Messieurs les les députés
donc je je suis en charge du service
affaires multilatéral et et
développement euh donc notamment en
charge du Club de Paris euh avec notre
directeur général Emmanuel moulin euh et
donc au quotidien sur sur les sujets de
restructuration de dett euh de suivi de
l'évolution de de l'endettement mais
nous nous couvrons aussi la le volet
financement euh puisque nous euh nous
gérons les les les les banques
multilatérales de
développement notre représentation fond
monétaire internationale et puis aussi
les les relation bilatérales avec avec
les pays d'Afrique subsaharienne et la
cotutelle de l'Agence française de
développement et sur les sujets de
coopération monétaire on travaille au au
quotidien avec nos nos collègues de de
la Banque de France donc ça ça nous
permet d'avoir une vision un peu
intégrée de de tout ce qui a été
présenté par Monsieur Jacques ma et
effectivement le je dirais les les les
enjeux de restructuration de dett c'est
un petit morceau du du du sujet le
monsieur Jacques ma
a me permet de ne pas avoir besoin de
revenir sur sur le contexte j'insisterai
sur le volet budgétaire euh ce que ce
qu'on l' voit c'est que il y a eu une
phase très difficile hein pendant les
pendant le covid euh puis donc le choc
du covid le choc de Ukraine les prix des
matières premières donc les et des
besoins spécifiques liés à la sécurité
liés au aux catastrophes naturelles donc
effectivement du côté des dépenses il y
a eu beaucoup de de pression pour pour
augmenter les dépenses et une capacité à
les à les financer bien moindre que ce
qu'on a pu avoir dans nos pays du fait
d'une d'une politique monétaire d'une
structuration financière totalement
différente donc effectivement c'est des
pays qui ont dû augmenter leur déficit
mais d'une certaine manière moins que
nous
et l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est de
retrouver une trajectoire soutenable je
crois que plus que le niveau de de la
dette c'est souvent la trajectoire qui
compte et c'est aussi les les règles
budgétaire qu'on qu'on se donne pour
assurer une soutenabilité à à moyen
terme dans dans les échanges qu'on a
aujourd'hui avec le le Fond Monétaire
International sur sur l'analyse des des
différents pays il nous dit les les
recommandations sont pas de de de
revenir à immédiatement à à des déficits
plus faibles mais d'avoir cette
trajectoire et derrière il y a l'enjeu
de baisser des des dépenses qui qui ne
sont pas efficaces euh de par exemple
les subventions à la consommation
d'énergie fossile euh c'est des choses
qui sont euh qui bénéficie pas pas pas
pas du tout de manière préférentielle au
au aux personnes les les les plus
pauvres euh donc on a des et ça peut
représenter plusieurs points de PIB de
dans dans un budget de dans un budget
d'un état euh il y a euh et donc c'est
on peut regarder du côté des dépenses on
peut aussi regarder du côté des recettes
et euh ça les les situations sont
différentes selon les pays mais on voit
que GL globalement le niveau des
recettes fiscales est quand même faible
et donc il y a aussi une marge du côté
de l'augmentation des des recettes
l'augmentation des basses taxables
relèvement de certaines de certains
niveaux de d'imposition ça fait partie
de de la solution maintenant comme comme
cela a été présenté ça n'enlève en rien
le fait que que ces pays ont des besoins
de financement extrêmement importants
que ce soit pour les objectifs de
développement de de du pays ou que pour
les enjeux climatiques euh ou autres et
et et sécuritaire et donc la question
qui se pose c'est la capacité de ces
pays à trouver les financements euh donc
ils ont un d'un besoin de de de
financement public euh quelle est la
source de ce financement donc il y a des
sources internes euh et puis il y a des
sources externes ce qu'on a vu c'est que
avec les les collègues de la Banque de
France qu'on ce c'est dans beaucoup de
pays se sont développés des des marchés
financiers locaux euh des des émissions
de dettes euh souscrit par les les
banques locales donc ça ça c'est
beaucoup développé mais on atteint un
peu un une limite quand même en terme
d'exposition des des banques locales euh
en terme prudentiel vis-à-vis vis-à-vis
du du souverain donc c'est des choses
qui peuvent continuer à se développer et
je crois qu'il faut on continue à à
promouvoir des marchés financiers locaux
euh pour pour diversifier les les
ressources de financement mais voilà
c'est ça ça a des limites aussi ce ce
financement interne s'agissant du du
financement externe en Afrique il y a
quand même assez peu de pays qui ont un
accès au marchés financiers
internationaux et à des émissions de
d'eurobonds donc sur sur le le marché
obligataire international assez peu de
pays et depuis 2 ans il n'y a depuis
2022 hein depuis début 2022 il il n'y a
plus vraiment d'émissions d'eurobonds
donc même les pays qui étaient je dirais
les plus avancés dans leur insertion
dans les marchés financiers
internationaux ils ont vu euh du fait de
la alors c'est une conjonction de
beaucoup de choses mais à la fois la la
remonté des des taux peut-être une
aversion au risque plus grande euh des
investisseurs internationaux au total
euh des des pays comme le Ghana des pays
comme le Kenya ne sont plus aujourd'hui
en situation de de pouvoir refinancer
aujourd'hui des eurobonds qui qu'ils ont
qu'ils ont en stock euh et par ailleurs
pour pour la plupart des pays le
financement externe est beaucoup un un
financement concessionnel
euh ou ou commercial mais qui est plus
bilatéral ou multilatéral donc pendant
beaucoup d'années euh le après les
l'initiative pays pauvre très endetté où
il y a on avait eu un constat euh euh
dans le début des années 2000 d'un excès
d'endettement des des pays africains et
puis une initiative commune pour pour
annuler la dette et et abaisser très
fortement le le stock de dette après
cette initiative qui a amené à beaucoup
d'annulation
euh on a vu des nouveaux créanciers
arriver à la fois la Chine et aussi le
les les les créanciers privés qui
peuvent être des des banques euh ou euh
dans dans certains pays des des des des
créanciers obligataires ce qui ce qu'on
voit c'est donc j'ai dit que le les
sources de financement c'était Taris là
de depuis un an sur les la partie
financement obligataire et ce qu'on voit
aussi c'est un retournement sur les
financements chinois
euh qui ont quand même qui ont beaucoup
porté les les les projets beaucoup de
projets d'infrastructure et autres dans
dans dans des pays d'Afrique et
aujourd'hui euh les on a un retournement
très fort des et dans certains pays plus
de plus de financement net du tout de de
la Chine donc ça ça fait un un un choc
important euh du côté de de l'aide au
développement euh on a eu l'année
dernière dans le contexte de la guerre
en Ukraine globalement une baisse des
flux d'aide au développement vers
l'Afrique c'est pas le cas de la France
nous avons continué à augmenter nos
financements d'aide au développement
vers l'Afrique mais quand même
globalement l'aide au développement
c'est c'est replié l'année l'année
dernière en Afrique donc effectivement
on a un sujet qui est et je crois qu'on
partage cette légitimité qu'il y a en
Afrique un besoin de financement
concessionnel de financement à à Bakou
c'était ça a été à l'origine hein de de
l'initiative de de notre président de
d'organiser un sommet sur le financement
des économie africaine en 2021 c'était
une reconnaissance de la légitimité de
cette question et pour trouver des des
solutions reconnaître que euh euh
certaines possibilités queon a dans dans
dans nos pays développés ne ne sont pas
ne sont pas disponibles dans un contexte
de de crise en 2021 de crise covid donc
euh qu'est-ce qu'on a fait euh en 2021
on a de soutenu une dynamique euh de euh
de de direction de de financement euh
vers vers l'Afrique il a eu euh
l'allocation exceptionnelle de droit de
tirage spéciaux du fonds monétairees
internationaux l'Afrique en bénéficie
très peu compte tenu de de son faible
poids au au Fond Monétaire International
et l'idée c'était que on
on on dirige des des prêts de droit de
tirage spéciaux vers vers l'Afrique donc
Infiné comment on le fait on le fait par
l'intermédiaire d'outil du du du Fond
Monétaire International je pourrais y
revenir mais on a une on a eu une
mobilisation de 100 milliards de droits
de tirage spéciaux de la loocation de
2000 21 qui sont dans les réserves des
des des des pays développés des pays qui
n'ont pas de problème de de de balance
de de paiement pour les mobiliser vers
les pays vulnérables et en en grande
partie en Afrique on a eu aussi des
appels à avoir des reconstitutions
ambitieuses de des poches
concessionnelles he des des en don ou en
prêt à très très bas taux d'intérêt de
la Banque mondiale de la banque
africaine donc il y a eu vraiment cette
reconnaissance qu'il y avait besoin
besoin et c'est ce qu'on appelait de
plus en plus un choc de financement pour
les pays africains et plus généralement
pour beaucoup de pour beaucoup de de
pays vulnérables euh s'agissant de de de
de la dette euh ce qui a été fait lors
de la période du covid c'est une
initiative de suspension du du service
de la dette donc on on on stoppe les les
remboursements mais ils ne sont pas
annulés ils sont juste rééchelonnés à
avec le même taux d'intérêt donc c'était
pour alléger un peu les les paiements
pour dans les dans les dans les flux
venant des des pays africains donc ils
aient plus de ressources disponibles
pour faire face aux difficultés du
moment mais ça ne règle pas de un des
sujets de structurels de de de de niveau
de dette et donc on a mis en place fin
2021 un cadre commun euh entre les pays
du Club de Paris donc on va alors ce ne
sont pas que les les pays qu'on qualifie
de développé au sens strict on a
maintenant par exemple Brésil hein qui
est membre du Club de Paris et on a
l'Afrique du Sud qui est en processus de
devenir membre donc voilà le le je pense
qu'il faut aussi faire renouveler cette
image du du Club de Paris c'est une
structure qui demeure attractive pour
des pays émergentss qui sont qui sont
créanciers donc euh
c'était cette initiative ce cadre commun
c'était le constat que on ne pouvait
plus faire ce qu'on a fait dans les
années 2000 une initiative de
restructuration partant uniquement du du
du du Club de Paris et du Fond Monétaire
International et qui fallait un vrai
dialogue avec la Chine qui était qui est
aujourd'hui dans le stock de dette le
souvent le le créancier officiel le plus
gros il y avait un deuxième constat qui
était que le Fond Monétaire
International et on lui pose la question
régulièrement nous dit que nous ne
sommes pas aujourd'hui dans un risque
systémique de crise de dette qu'il y a
des pays à regarder à traiter si besoin
mais que nous ne sommes pas dans une
situation où il faudrait faire une une
réduction
euh transversale automatique du stock de
dette des pays et qu'il faut regarder au
cas par cas donc ça c'est un principe
très important de de ce cadre commun on
fait les choses au cas par au cas par
cas et est extrêmement articulé avec le
le Fond Monétaire International et et la
Banque mondiale donc on c'est un peu
notre quotidien avec Philippe guillonet
du perra qui est derrière moi et qui est
secrétaire général du du Club de Paris
on a euh on a traité le sujet du Tchad
euh il y a quelques mois alors quand on
quand le chad a demandé une
restructuration de dett les prix du
pétrole étaient bas euh le temps qu'on
parce qu'il y a un problème de de timing
he de on a un processus qui est trop
lent et c'est des critiques qui qui sont
qui sont justifié mais le temps qu'on
met en place le un traitement de dette
entre-temps le pétrole avait beaucoup
remonté et il n'y avait plus besoin
qu'on fasse un trait traitement de dette
quantitatif voilà on s'est engagé en cas
de prix du pétrole bas à à faire un
faire un traitement de dette mais ce
qu'on a fait c'est que on a donné à au
Tchad un levier pour négocier une un
reprofilage des des paiements envers son
principal créancier qui est un créancier
privé qui était glenc euh donc ce ce
cadre commun donne du poids donne du
levier à à des pays débiteur pour
négocier avec avec les les créanciers
avec les créanciers privés on est en ce
moment on finalise le le cas de la
Zambie qui est un peu le premier
traitement de de dette extrêmement
important en terme d'effort on ne fait
pas du côté des créanciers officiels une
annulation d' d'une partie de la dette
mais ce que l'on fait c'est un
reprofilage oui c'est un
reprofilage très fort on change
totalement les les flux de paiement sur
l'ensemble sur sur l'ensemble des dettes
et ça fait une une réduction en terme de
valeur actualisée nette he on regarde un
peu la valeur aujourd'hui de l'ensemble
des flux futurs et on baisse de 40 % la
valeur on va dire he de de notre dette
en vue d'aujourd'hui et donc c'est c'est
des efforts importants on est on a une
signature en cours de d'un d'un accord
entre la Zambie et le comité de
créanciers tous ces comités de
créanciers on les a présidés coprésidé
entre la France et l'Arabie Saoudite
pour le Tchad et la France et la Chine
pour la Zambie pour l'Éthiopie et pour
le Ghana donc on est en train de on est
proche de la on a fini on va dire pour
la Zambie on on donne du levier à la
Zambie pour négocier avec les créanciers
obligataires on a quasi fini pour le
Ghana il faut encore qu'on qu'on qu'on
mette les choses par écrit qu'on ait un
un accord ferme et puis on sur
l'Éthiopie on attend un accord entre le
FMI et et les et l'Éthiopie pour pouvoir
faire le le traitement donc on a mis en
place des ces choses-là sur la les
restructurations de dett et on regarde
en parallèle aussi comment on peut par
exemple c'est un tout autre sujet mais
introduire des clauses qui interrompent
automatiquement les les le paiement du
service de la dette en cas de
catastrophe naturelle c'est aussi un
autre volet sur sur lequel on travaille
et le sommet qui a eu lieu en juin et
voilà ma dernière phrase le sommet qui a
eu lieu en juin dernier à Paris un
nouveau pacte financier a non seulement
reconnu tout toutes ces avancées mais a
aussi couvert des questions que vous
avez posé monsieur le Président sur
l'importance d' avancer sur des
nouvelles sources de financement donc il
y a une Task Force qui va se mettre en
place à l'issue du sommet de juin pour à
essayer de donner une impulsion
politique plus forte sur des sujets
comme la taxation maritime la taxation
de de l'aérien avoir plus de pays qui
mettent la taxe sur les transactions
financières comme nous voilà je m'arrête
là et je répondrai à vos questions bien
sûr merci merci enfin la parole est à
Bruno Cabriac de la Banque de France à
qui si j'ose dire je demande de faire
preuve d'un esprit de synthèse pour
lutter contre l'inflation des temps de
parole je vais essayer de faire de faire
le maximum et d'aller et d'aller assez
vite donc je travaille à la direction
générale des études et de
l'Internationale de la Banque de France
la direction générale comprend une unité
qui est un peu à la marge du mandat de
la Banque de France mais qui s'occupe
pour le compte de l'état des questions
de de financement de financement du du
développement en général et donc on
travaille comme l'a dit William Ros très
étroitement avec la direction générale
du Trésor je vais centrer ma
présentation sur les pays de l'ex zone
frontc comme ça m'a été
demandé et donc euh pourquoi l'ex zone
franc et bien parce que on a on a changé
ce vocable
euh premièrement parce que c'était un
irritant à l'égard de nos partenaires
africains et deuxièmement pour corriger
aussi une inexactitude parce que il ne
s'agissait pas contrairement à ce qu'on
a dit et ce qu'on entend encore
aujourd'hui d'une véritable zone
monétaire
c'est un ensemble de pays qui a des
accords de coopération monétaire avec la
Banque de France et qui comprend en fait
trois zones monétaires qui sont des
zones totalement différentes et euh
c'est je pense utile de rappeler parce
que euh je remarquais que dans certains
euh rapports parlementaires récents on
ne signalait pas encore ce fait il y a
deux fronts CFA et pas un seul franc CFA
et ce sont deux monnaies euh totalement
différentes et qui ne sont pas librement
convertibles entre elles et donc la
seule chose qui rassemble je dirais ces
pays qu'on appelle maintenant la euh les
pays euh de coopération euh monétaire
Afrique France donc ça a été difficile
de trouver euh ce vocable euh qui je le
reconnais pas particulièrement
euh pnémonique mais en tout cas il y a
une seule chose qui rassemble ce groupe
de pays c'est d'avoir des accords
monétaires avec la France qui reposent
sur les mêmes principes même si ils sont
différents avec des textes différents et
en fait ces accords de coopération
monétaire c'est aussi le résultat d'un
choix librement exercé par ces pays sur
leur régime de change un double choix
euh notamment pour les pays de l'UMOA et
de la semmac qui ont fait le choix
d'être d'une part en union monétaire et
d'autre part d'avoir un taux de change
fixe vis-à-vis de l'Euro donc c'est un
double régime de change rigide qui est
unique au monde et donc les accords de
coopération monétaire avec la France je
le rappelle c'est que la France donne sa
garantie elle donne sa garantie à
chacune des banques centrales donc à
chacune des zones monétaire et non pas à
chacun des États euh pour euh qui est on
appelle une garantie de change qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire en pratique ça veut
dire en fait que en cas d'épuisement des
réserves la France fournit de façon
illimitée et
inconditionnelle des réserves de change
à ces euh à ces pays
alors quels sont les avantages de ce
régime de change ils sont bien connus
sur le long terme ces des avantages en
terme de stabilité monétaire euh la
plupart des études qui ont été faites
sur ce régime sur le très long terme
montre que ça n'a pas d'effet
significatif alors c'est très difficile
évidemment à déterminer puisque c'est
très difficile de faire des
contrefactuels ça n'a pas d'effet
significatif sur la croissance à long
terme ni en bien ni en mal mais par
contre ça a un effet important sur la
stabilité monétaire et si vous regardez
le graphique d'en haut vous voyez que
sur une dizaine d'années en terme de
réserve de valeur
le Fran CFA est les Fran CFA sont très
efficaces puisque l'inflation cumulée
est très significativement inférieure à
celle qu'elle est dans les autres pays
d'Afrique sub
saharienne
c'est c'est le le graphique d'en haut et
sur le graphique d'en bas ben vous vous
voyez que en terme de de
croissance c'est des performances à peu
près comparables depuis le début du
siècle avec le reste de l'Afrique
subsaharienne sur la période la plus
récente j'attire votre attention sur la
courbe jaune qui rassemble l'ensemble
des pays du
Sahel donc les pays du Sahel de l'UMOA
plus le Tchad et vous voyez que en terme
de croissance leur performance malgré
tous les chocs qu'ils ont subis et on y
reviendra courtement tout à l' àheur
malgré tous les chocs qu'ils ont subis
ils ont leur croissance a été
relativement résiliante et là c'est là
que apparaît de mon point de vue le
principal avantage de ce régime de
change et de cette coopération monétaire
qui permet la crédibilité de ce régime
de change c'est que dans des pays avec
des troubles sécuritaires très
importants affectés de chocs très
important et bien euh la valeur de la
monnaie reste intacte et la monnaie
quelque part préservé de l'ensemble de
ces chocs elle est doublement préservée
par les unions monétaires et par le
régime de change fixe et ça c'est
peut-être l'avantage le plus déterminant
donc c'est vraiment dans les périodes de
crise et aussi dans les périodes de
poussé inflationniste international
comme aujourd'hui qu'on voit l'avantage
de de de ce régime de change et
effectivement si on regarde ce qui se
passe sur cette année 2023 et bien et
bien on voit que la croissance est
relativement résiliante dans les pays de
l'UMOA mais aussi dans les pays de la
sac en considérant que les pays de la
CMAC sont essentiellement des pays
exportateurs de pétrole aujourd'hui et
que ces pays sont en convalescence après
la crise entraînée en 2014 par le
retournement des prix du pétrole on voit
que ils ont aussi réussi à améliorer ou
en tout cas à limiter la détérioration
de leurs fondamentaux williamos parlait
tout à l'heure de l'endettement public
on voit que les ratios d'endettement
public sont plus faibles euh dans ces
pays que dans le reste de l'Afrique
subsaharienne qu'ils ont encore des
réserves de change
substantielles et ça
euh ça se c'est ça ce sont des
fondamentaux qui se sont améliorés
malgré le fait que ces pays ont utilisé
un peu plus leur marge de manœuvre
budgétaire et leur marge de manœuvre
monétaire pour faire face à la crise
covid et continue à les utiliser vous
voyez notamment que dans les pays de
l'UMOA le solde budgétaire reste
relativement dégradé le sold de courant
reste relativement dégradé on pourrait
l'interpréter négativement mais
l'interprétation positive c'est que ils
ont pu utiliser et notamment grâce à
nouveau à ce régime de change leur marge
de manœuvre budgétaire pour faire face
aux nombreuses crises qui sont celles
aujourd'hui de l'ensemble de l'Afrique
sub-saharienne mais particulièrement
forte en UMOA qui souffre des éléments
qu'à signalé William rus du
ralentissement de la croissance mondiale
de pression inflationniste persistant
dans le monde des dururcissement des
conditions de financement qui extérieur
notamment la fermeture des marchés de
capitaux aux pays d'Afrique
sub-saharienne qui touche aussi
fortement l'UMOA le recul des
financements euh des financements
concessionnels d'APD dans l'Afrique
subsaharienne et puis la baisse des
financements chinois à ça s'ajoute les
tensions sécuritaires les politiques que
vous connaissez bien notamment dans les
pays du Sahel et un autre une
vulnérabilité au changement climatique
qui est très forte notamment dans les
pays du sel j'ai mis dans la carte
l'indice de
vulnérabilité calculé par la Ferdi et
qui montre effectivement que les pays du
Sahel sont parmis et notamment pour des
raisons de vari climatique de sécheresse
d'absence aussi d'irrigation sont parmi
les pays qui sont les plus sensibles au
risqu physiques liés au changement
climatique
pourtant la performance de l'UMOA depuis
le début du siècle et même dans les
années récentes comme l'illustre sur ce
tableau montre que ces pays sont sont
particulièrement résilients et à nouveau
je voulais signaler la résilience des
pays du Sahel au sein de l'UMOA le Mali
le
Niger le
BurkinaFaso dont les performances
macro-économiques selon les chiffres de
la BCEAO qui sont selon notre point de
vue relativement fiables n'ont pas été
fortement affectés malgré la dégradation
de la situation sécuritaire et les coups
d'État militaires les coups d'État
militaires se sont généralement traduit
par une petite poussée d'inflation euh
juste dans les mois qui ont suivi ces
coups d'État militaires mais pas par une
régression forte malgré les sanction une
régression forte du taux de du taux de
croissance il y a effectivement dans
cette zone comme d'ailleurs dans la zone
CMAC un rôle déterminant du FMI pour
assurer que ces pays mène une politique
macro-économique favorable à la
croissance et et et au au développement
sur le sur le long terme alors ce qui se
passe en SEMAC est un petit peu
différent de ce qui se passe en umaoa
parce que la semmac c'est effectivement
des pays exportateurs de pétrole donc
ils ont vécu d'une façon différente le
choc énergétique mais ils étaient en
convalescence à cause du du retournement
des prix pétroliers à la baisse en 2014
et donc la crise covid les frappe en
pleine reprise
économique et pourtant là aussi la
croissance a été relativement résiliante
y compris dans des pays comme le Tchad
qui
sont qui sont victimes des mêmes
vulnérabilité notamment en matière
sécuritaire et en matière climatique que
des pays de l'UMOA et donc là aussi si
on compare la situation par rapport à
d'autres pays exportateurs de pétrole
notamment l'Angola ou le
Nigeria on voit que le régime de change
a apporté un premier avantage qui est
celui de la stabilité monétaire il y a
pas eu cet enchaînement entre hausse des
prix inflation détérioration du taux de
change et donc cette spirale prix taux
de change qui s'est passé
au au nigerria ou en Angola par contre
sur le long terme et ça c'est
effectivement une remarque
peut-être un peu décevante aussi sur les
avantages du système on aurait pu penser
que le régime de taux de change fixe par
nature limiter les effets de ce qu'on
appelle le syndrome
hollandais et en fait ces pays n'ont pas
fait plus de progrès en matière de
diversification économique et de sortie
progressive des énergies fossiles ou en
tout cas de la dépendance trop forte à
aux énergies fossiles pas plus
d'ailleurs que le nigerriia ou l'Angola
euh mais ça ne les a pas aidé sur ce
plan structurel voilà donc je voudrais
conclure que
cette ce ce ce système ce système de
change dans la conjoncture actuelle avec
une forte poussée
inflationniste internationale et qui
s'est développé dans un certain nombre
de pays à faible revenu par la spirale
détérioration de change
et inflation et bien cette ce régime de
change a eu des avantages a des
avantages aujourd'hui qu'on voit et qui
sont et qui sont
significatifs bien merci ah il faut
Coupier votre micro pardon merci
messieur de ces interventions
complémentaires euh passionnantes et
dont certaines reviennent sur peut-être
des idées trop préconçues donc je pense
que ça va ouvrir pas mal la discussion
juste avant de passer la parole au
rapporteur général et aux orateurs de
groupe je dans mon intervention il y
avait deux questions et je je je suis
resté un peu sur ma fin non pas sur la
question de la dette vous avez répondu
mais en tout cas sur la question de de
l'impact de la bifurcation écologique
dans la prise en compte justement de
financement supplémentaire enfin en tout
cas j'ai j'ai pas entendu de de réponses
qui m'ont qui m'ont forcément satisfait
et également sur alors j'ai compris que
vous aviez euh euh vous aviez monsieur
monsieur Cabriac louer un peu le le
régime de change mais je reste quand
même interrogateur je reste avec des
interrogation
sur la récente réforme qui qui instaure
un parité avec l'euro et que pour ma
part je juge peut-être pénalisant pour
les exportations et les compétitités
économies africaines don je veux bien
que vous réagissiez là-dessus c'était
avant que vous arriviez c'est pour ça
monsieur cabri bien je vais passer la
parole au rapporteur général juste on
prend prend le la méthode commission des
finances je sais pas si c'est une
méthode habituelle pour les commissaires
euh de la du la commission défense
c'est-à-dire on donne la parole aux
orateurs de groupe pour 2 minutes chacun
et après il y a une série de réponses et
après on passe aux orateurs
supplémentaires mais j'ouvre avec le
rapporteur général jeanoné
casenu merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
pour cette
intervention très très éclairante
d'abord dire que rappeler à tout le
monde que l'aide publique au
développement 2023 c'est 15,9 milliards
d'euros en progression de 700 millions
d'euros par rapport à
2022 la France notre pays tient ses
engagements on avait annoncé une montée
en puissance une programmation de l'aide
publique au développement aujourd'hui
c'est 0,55 % de notre revenu national
brut on tient nos engagements et c'est
important de le de le rappeler j'aurais
quatre questions rapides la première
c'est que la France justement dans cette
aide continue à à comptabiliser
l'annulation de dettes et généralement
l'action sur l'endettement des pays
africains est-ce que c'est une pratique
que moi je trouve assez normale est-ce
qu'elle est est-ce qu'elle est je sais
qu'elle est discutée jeen avoir votre
avis là-dessus et savoir si c'est la
norme aussi pour d'autres pays qui qui
prêtent 2uxème question vous avez
beaucoup parlé l'instabilité de ces pays
de l'achat des ES
aussi des sujets de transition
écologique des sujets de de visa quel
est le contrôle aujourd'hui que nous
avons sur
l'utilisation de cette aide publique au
au au développement vis-à-vis de ces de
ces pays 3è question
euh il y a eu une la volonté exprimée
par le Président de la République de la
fin du du franc CFA quels sont les
points d'attention auquel le
gouvernement sera confronté dans le
casadre de la mise en re de cette Pr
promesse est-ce que c'est une promesse
qui qui de votre point de vue va être
tenue et quand et enfin ma ma dernière
question c'est quel est le niveau de
sinistralité de la dette aujourd'hui au
pays africains je vous remercie merci on
va passer à Philippe sorz pour le groupe
renaissance pour 2
minutes merci monsieurs les présidents
mes chers collègues au nom du groupe
Renaissance je tiens tout d'abord à
exprimer mes sincères remerciements à
nos trois intervenants pour leur venue
ce matin au sein de commission je vous
égement saluer la qualité de leurs
propos et de leurs expertises qui
constitueront à éclairer nos débats dans
le cadre du cycle Afrique vous le savez
les liens historiques entre la France et
l'Afrique se distinguent
particulièrement par le soutien et la
coopération dans deux domaines clés la
défense et la monnaie la coopération
dans le secteur monétaire a été marquée
par une certaine inertie générant des
critiques et des mouvements de
contestation dirigé en particulier
contre le
francfa ainsi en mai 2020 le président
ivoiri
Alassan ara et le président français
Emmanuel Macron ont officiellement
validé la réforme du Fran CFA en
reconnaissant que cette monnaie était
perçue comme un vestige de la
France-Afrique cet accord entre le
Trésor français et la banque centrale
des États d'Afrique de l'Ouest implique
deux changements majeurs l'arrêt du
versement de 50 % des réserves de change
de la zone sur le compte d'opération du
Trésor français et le retrait de la
France des instances de gouvernance de
la devise cependant un point crucial
demeure inchangé pour le moment la
France continue de garantir le Fran
CFA cet étape représente une transition
avant le remplacement du Fran CFA par
l'cho censé devenir la future devise
commune de la Communauté économique des
États de l'Afrique de l'Ouest alors que
cette réforme a eu un retentissement
considérable au moment de son annonce le
Fran CFA reste donc le symbole de
l'ensemble des difficultés économiques
de la zone franc et parfois même un
prétexte pour des revendications plus
large contre la présence française en
Afrique à cet égard quel regard
portez-vous sur cette réforme et comment
évlez-vous ses impacts économiqu et
politique 3 ans après sa mise en œuvre
concernant l'avenir du projet de
transition vers l'écho et la disparition
du Fran CFA en Afrique de l'Est quelle
perspective pouvons-nous envisager
mercitat ah pardon merci Éric Salmond
pour le groupe rassemblement national
monsieur le Président Messieurs les
Présidents mes chers collègues merci
déjà messieurs pour vos présentations le
28 novembre 2017 le président Emmanuel
Macron a affirmé qu'il ne faisait pas du
maintien de l'existence de la zone de
coopération monétaire je je réutilise
votre expression des francefa un dogme
il a rappelé l'importance du resp
respect de la souveraineté des États
africains en la matière en parlant de
ces derniers il déclarait je le cite
s'ils considèrent qu'il faut même
supprimer totalement cette stabilité
régionale et que c'est mieux pour eux je
considère que c'est eux qui décident et
donc je suis favorable nous nous
reconnaissons pleinement de cette
position de respect de la souveraineté
des États un certain nombre de pays ont
fait le choix de quitter la zone de
coopération monétaire francfa comme la
Guinée ou la Mauritanie je ne pense pas
qu'il soit dans l'intérêt de ces pays de
quitter cette zone de coopération
facteur de stabilité économique mais si
telle est leur décision souveraine ainsi
soit-il en revanche il me semble que
l'on étudie beaucoup et a raison
l'intérêt de l'existence des francfa
pour les États membres africains et pas
assez l'intérêt pour la France des
franceç FAA ma question est donc la
suivante existe-t-il des études
économiques de prospective anticipant
les conséquences pour coraurit pour la
France une une disparition du franc FAA
au-delà de l'hypothèse d'une disparition
de la zone existe-t-il des études
économiques sur les inconvénients et les
avantages de l'existence du Fran CFA
pour déterminer si le maintien de cette
zone monétaire est dans l'intérêt de la
France je vous
remercie merci on va passer à David
guirud pour la France
soumise merci monsieur le Président
merci à vous pour cette audition très
intéressante je rappelle quelquesunes de
nos positions qui tient à dire qu'il
faut annuler en partie les dettes
d'états africain de permettre aux pays
africains des zones CFA dont la partie
ouest est devenue ch d'avoir une monnaie
dont ils soitent les seuls maîtres les
seuls maîtres et dont ils puissent
définir les contours et chez nous
consacré 0,7 % de notre revenu national
brut à l'aide publique au développement
en octobre 2023 un entretien d'Émilie
lafito qui a été publié par l'iris
dresse trois scénarios pour l'avenir
monétaire des États qui utilisent le
franc CFA d'abord une monnaie commune
aux 15 pays de la CDAO ensuite la
création d'une monnaie unique au sein de
l'UMA et enfin la fin d'une monnaie
commune et la création de monnaie
nationale quel scénario à vous vous
semble le plus probable dans quelle
mesure est-ce que les trajectoires
politique et sécuritaire auxquel font
face certains états pourraient
influencer ces trajectoires politiques
et enfin dans la mesure où la mise en
œuvre de projet d'émancipation
économique et financière annoncé par les
présidents Macron et ara en décembre
2019 est aujourd'hui il faut le
reconnaître au point mort comment
permettre aux pays africains des zones
CFA d'avoir une monnaie dont ils soient
les seuls maîtres et dont ils puissent
définir les contours tout en leur
garantissant une stabilité monétaire je
vous
remercie merci euh Jean-Louis tiraau
pour les
républicains merci Messieurs les
Présidents mes chers collègues d'abord
très très intéressé par ce cet exposé
qui nous a bien éclairé avant de de
poser ma question je voudrais simplement
dire au nom de notre groupe une légère
divergence sur les présupposés et je
pense au propos de Monsieur jacquesemot
concernant la
légitimité des financements euh à
l'Afrique je crois qu'il ne faut pas
raisonner en terme de légitimité qu'il y
ait eu des externalités négatives venant
euh des pays développés c'est tout à
fait évident mais il y a aussi des
externalités positives dont il faut
tenir compte je pense au progrès en
matière par exemple sanitaire de
mortalité infantile ou tous ces
éléments-là et on ne peut pas je crois
dire que il y a une on va dire
culpabilité collective que devrait avoir
le monde euh euh développé vis-à-vis des
pays africains cela posé si les
présupposés ne sont pas les mêmes le
résultat auquel nous arrivons est
exactement le même c'est-à-dire que pour
éviter davantage d'externalités négative
partout et davantage de difficultés nous
avons effectivement une nécessité
absolue d'être présent en Afrique et de
participer au financement du
développement des économies africaine de
la transition écologique parce que sinon
on sait bien que les problématiques
d'une manière ou d'une autre et
notamment démographiqu deviendront des
problèmes qui toucheront l'Europe et et
en général et la France en particulier
donc ma question qui rejoint d'ailleurs
la question de celle du rapporteur génér
c'est dans votre propos on a très peu
évoqué les problématiques de gouvernance
vous parliez de contrôle donc quelle est
votre réflexion à tous les trois sur la
manière d'améliorer la gouvernance des
flux financiers qui peuvent aller vers
l'Afrique avec à la fois le problème de
la gouvernance étatique les coups d'État
qu'on évoquait mais aussi de la
gouvernance des entreprises
merci merci Mohamed pour group
démocrate
merci monsieur le Président merci
messieur pour votre
intervention je commencerai directement
par poser mes questions mais en citant
d'abord un proverbe
africain qui dit ceci la main qui donne
reste toujours au-dessus de celle qui
reçoit la main qui donne elle est
toujours au-dessus de celle qui reçoit
alors comment pouvons-nous
structurer notre relation économique
financière et sécuritaire pour qu'elle
soutient et qu'elle vient en soutien à
l'Afrique dans une relation plus
équilibrée et pour éviter ce cette
perpétuelle dynamique de
dépendance la deè question quelle
stratégie pouvons-nous adopter pour
renforcer cette autonomie économique et
sécuritaire des pays africains un accord
bien sûr avec ce principe de respect
mutuel en quoi la France France
peut-elle réviser sa politique
d'assistance et j'aime pas le mot
assistance d'aide au développement même
pour évoluer vers un partenariat donc
plus égalitaire avec les pays africains
favorisant leur développement durable et
leur stabilité à long terme enfin ne
devons-nous pas nous interroger sur
notre politique d'immigration dite
choisie et le sujet va être traité très
bientôt qui consiste finalement à
attirer des étudiants aujourd'hui pour
ensuite les
retenir privant l'Afrique de ce qu'il y
a de très cher de sa matière grise après
avoir exploité on a vu votre tableau
avec les flux financiers de l'Afrique
qui sortent par milliards aujourd'hui
chaque année il y a aussi cette matière
grise qui fait défaut à
l'Afrique merci je ne vois personne pour
le groupe socialiste auire de ma part
non lise manier pour le groupe
horizon bien le micro président merci
merci messieurs les présidents de
commission et merci messieurs les
orateurs pour votre présentation
complète effectivement que vous nous
avez faite ce matin je pense que nous
avons absolument tous conscience que
l'Afrique est au carrefour géographique
économique diplomatique et militaire de
notre monde et que la question des
besoins de financement pour faire face
aux enux majeur que nous vous nous avez
parfaitement rappelé est donc crucial
d'autant qu'aujourd'hui nous le
constatons l'Ouest et l'Est se font de
nouveaux face et cette contestation a
évidemment des conséquences pour le
continent africain et d'ailleurs les
investissements de la Chine et la
communication associé sont
symptomatiques d'une volonté d'expansion
économique entraînant un risque fort de
mainmise politique et diplomatique sur
le continent africain par des pays
autoritaires et cela associé évidemment
à des opérations de désinformations et
d'influence visant à opposer l'Afrique
et l'Europe et donc ma question sera la
suivante messieurs en quoi notre
politique de coopération monétaire
peut-elle enrayer ces opérations de
contestation des partenariats
euro-africains et particulièrement Fran
franco-africain je vous
remercie merci lise Karim benchek pour
le groupe
écologiste merci monsieur le Président
euh merci pour l'ensemble de ces
présentations je retiens
particulièrement euh les besoins de
financement qui ont été exprimés à un
moment donné pour dire que aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin de 285 milliards pour
la période post-covid et 200 milliards
par an pour atteindre les objectifs du
développement euh je retiens aussi qu'il
y a 40 milliards en total d'APD vers
l'Afrique donc visiblement nous sommes
dans un rapport de 1 à 10 si je
comprends bien entre besoins de
financement et ce qui est concrètement
financé j'ai retenu aussi l'intéressant
graphique montrant une corrélation entre
financement des armées et coups d'État
militaire est-ce qu'il serait pertinent
de faire un graphique sur la même
période entre démantellement du réseau
diplomatique au sens large et
détérioration de la relation avec
certains pays
euh par
ailleurs j'ai bien entendu les remarques
aussi du rapporteur général sur le
niveau de notre APD c'est vrai nous
devons nous en féliciter 15 milliards
désormais d'APD c'est un chiffre qui
n'avait jamais été atteint mais nous
savons aussi par ailleurs que nos outils
de coopération en matière de
développement reposent essentiellement
sur du prêt car les 15 milliards si nous
retranchons la partie bonification de
prêt si nous retranchons la partie
consacré à l'asile si nous retranchons
la partie recherche si nous retranchons
la partie étude en gros il ne reste plus
beaucoup de subvention nettes et on
repose notre outil de coopération
principalement sur du prê or pensez-vous
que cet outil euh nous permet est le
plus pertinent aujourd'hui pour répondre
aux défis que nous voyons en Afrique
sub-saharienne et surtout pour cibler
les zones que nous considérons comme
prioritaires
merci merci Jean-Marc Tellier pour le
groupe GDR oui merci messieur les
présidents chers collègues tout d'abord
je voudrais remercier les différents
orateurs le 18 octobre dernier était
publié le rapport de la Banque de France
sur la coopération monétaire entre la
France et et l'Afrique à la lecture de
celui-ci j'en arrive à plusieurs
conclusions tout d'abord l'Afrique a
besoin de financement massif et de
création monétaire la France doit doit
cesser sa mise sous dépendance de la
zone du franc FAA mais plus encore elle
doit agir au plan international pour
changer radicalement les règles
d'attribution des DTS du FMI au-delà
d'une nouvelle distribution des DTS non
utilisé par les pays riches qui se fait
actuellement au compte-goutte une
réforme des conditions d'émission des
DTS devrait favoriser les critères de
lutte contre la pauvreté et le
financement à grande échelle de la
transition économique et écologique du
continent africain par ailleurs les pays
africains ont besoin de nouvelles
recettes fiscales et nous devrions y
consacrer des efforts en cohérence avec
la réalisation des objectifs contenu
dans le Pacte international relatif aux
droits économiques et sociaux et
culturels que la France a ratifieré il
est souvent dit l'Afrique est notre
avenir mais elle est d'abord l'avenir
des Africains et c'est par là que tout
doit commencer et qu'avec eux nous
devrons surmonter les défis communs en
matière sociale climatique et
environnementale ainsi j'aurai deux
interrogations concernant les besoins de
recettes fiscales pourquoi ne pas
flécher au moins de 10 % l'aide publique
au développement vers le soutien et au
renforcement des systèmes fiscaux de ces
pays pour leur donner des moyens un
budgétaire de développement et de
financement endogène enfin alors que les
pays africains souhaitent retrouver de
la souveraineté monétaire comment
expliquer que 81 % des stocks d'or de la
branque centrale des États d'Afrique de
l'Ouest est toujours détenu par la
Banque de France je vous
remercie merci chers collègu Michel
Castellani pour
groupeot Charles de Courson
oui l'Afrique est le continent dont la
population croit le plus vite dans le
monde ce qui crée des besoins
considérables en matière d'éducation de
santé de logement et tout simplement de
développement économique or Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur vous signalez que le taux
de croissance économique de l'Afrique ne
peut absorber cette croissance
démographique donc quelles sont les
grandes mesures qui permettraient
d'ajuster l'offre et la et la demande en
la matière car si on réussit pas à
l'ajusté on aura des immigrations
massives on aura à l'intérieur de
l'Afrique entre l'Afrique et l'Europe on
aura ces coup d'État militaire enfin
permanent des régimes euh autoritaire
qui s'installent un peu partout bon
voilà c'est ce ce qui nous P est alors
voilà quelles sont les grandes mesures
les grandes politiques qui permettraiit
politique démographique de freinage de
la croissance
démographique l'aide au développement
est-ce que notre système d'aide au
développement permet vraiment le
développement de l'Afrique la politique
monétaire c'est un peu la couverture sur
le manteau si je peux dire c'est pas
forcément ça qui permet le le
développement
économique merci comme on est borné par
le temps c'est-à-dire à 11h on doit
rendre la salle on va passer aux
question supplémentairire je repasse la
parole à mon co-président du jour et là
c'est pas plus d'une minute par personne
merci très bien merci monsieur le
Président l'appareil est à Valérie Baz
malgr merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues messieurs je vous merci
pour vos propos liminires la situation
financière en Afrique est préoccupante
l'endettement en Afrique sub-saharienne
a presque doublé en 10 ans passant de 30
% du PIB en 2013 à environ 60 % du PIB
en 2022 ceci induit que le coût du
remboursement de la dette a aussi
augmenté le ratio paiement de d'intérêt
et recettes a été multiplié par plus de
deux depuis le début des années 2010
plus de la moitié des pays en Afrique
subsaharienne présentent un risque de
surendettement élevé où sont en
surendettement effectivement
l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt
entraîne des difficultés de
remboursement notamment pour les pays
endettés cela accroit le fardeau
financier rend les remboursements plus
coûteux et influence négativement
l'économie la situation est très
inquiétante j'aimerais savoir messieurs
quelles actions spécifiques vous
recommandez pour atténuer ces problèmes
de remboursement liés à l'augmentation
des taux d'intérêt je vous remercie
merci la parole est à yannique favenec B
merci monsieur le Président avec le
budget consacré la FD la France est
dotée d'un outil de développement très
puissant pour autant il est peu visible
sur le terrain puisque les populations
concernées l'ignor et ne l'associe pas à
l'amélioration de leur situation alors
que préconisez-vous pour réformer la
stratégie politique politique de la FD
comment rendre cette action plus visible
et lisible pour les populations que
préconisez-vous concernant la réforme du
Fran CFA la France doit-elle selon vous
attendre la décision des pays concernés
ou faut-il leur fixer une échéance je
vous remercie merci la parole est à
patrickzel merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président messieur les présidents merci
beaucoup de nous avoir permis de d'avoir
cet échange ce matin ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur
Ross en fait dans votre intervention
monsieur Ros vous avez insisté sur le
fait que dans un passé récent il y a eu
des investissements chinois assez
conséquents sur le continent Afrique
africain et vous avez précisé euh dans
dans un second temps qu'il y avait sur
un certain nombre de pays désormais euh
un un recul de ces investissements
chinois est-ce que vous pouvez
simplement nous préciser euh quel a été
la la hauteur de ces investissements
chinois au cours de la dernière décennie
et euh quels sont les pays qui sont
aujourd'hui concerné par un retrait
d'investissement de de la part de de la
Chine puisque on voit bien que cela
entre très largement en conflit avec un
certain nombre de politiques à la fois
français et européenne je vous remercie
merci enfin la parole est à
Marie-Christine dalallose merci monieurs
les présidents merci pour vos
interventions messieurs à vos différents
titre je voudrais que vous puissiez nous
confirmer les propos de Monsieur
jacquesem à savoir quand il dit que les
besoins financiers sont considérables
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
l'évaluation qu'il a qu'il a qu'il a
donné enfin le les accords de
coopération dit monétaire est-ce que
dans accord de coopération il est prévu
d'aider les
pays sub d'Afrique subsaharienne à
traiter les 90 milliards d'euros de flux
financiers perdu annuellement parce que
ça c'est quand même une conséquence
directe sur l'économie et enfin ma
dernière question vous dites que dans
les pays de la CMAC l'inflation en 2023
va être estimée à 5 7 que la croissance
du PIB sera 27 le delta est assez
conséquent quand même et quels sont les
les impacts que vous imaginer par
rapport notamment à la capacité de
remboursement de la dette merci mes
chers collègues pour l'ensemble de cette
question alors il nous reste 30 minutes
et nous avons trois orateurs alors même
si je ne suis pas membre de la
commission des finances j'arrive à
calculer un budget temps pour chacun
d'environ 10 minutes mais avant cela
nous avons une dernière intervention de
Monsieur Castellani
oui merci président merci pour au
rapporteur euh non j'aimerais intervenir
juste une seconde sur les éléments
suivants la croissance démographique en
Afrique a été l'an dernier de 23 pour
1000 23,4 exactement ce qui signifie que
quand il y avait 1000 africain au 1er
janvier ils étaient 1023 au 31 décembre
c'est une croissance
considérable
qui qui qui qui qui nous interpelle ça
veut dire que pour augmenter le revenu
individuel
le revenu moyen individuel donc le
développement cela supposerait une
formation brute de capital tout à fait
considéraable que l'on peut d'ailleurs
calculer mais c'est pas l'endroit ici
donc ma question est la suivante est-ce
que l'endettement africain auprès de la
France particulier vous
semble-t-il vraiment un vecteur de
développement est-ce que cette ces dons
ou ou ces prêts vont-ils dans vraiment
toujours faire des secteurs moteurs et
et inducteur de développement merci
merci je vous propose de donner la
parole à nos orateur dans l'ordre
inverse de l'intervention initiale la
parole est donc à Monsieur Gabriac de la
Banque de France
oui merci monsieur le rapporteur je je
vais commencer peut-être par répondre à
la question euh du président sur euh euh
le système de change est- ce qu'il
pénalise la
compétitivité des pays de la de la
coopération monétaire Afrique Afrique
France euh et bien ce qu'on a vu dans
les années 90 avant la dévaluation de
1994 ne s'est pas reproduit depuis cette
dévaluation si on regarde les
estimations que fait le FMI le taux de
change n'est pas n'a jamais été depuis
cette dévaluation de 94 durablement
surévalué par rapport au taux de change
d'équilibre il a pas non plus été
durablement
sous-évalué et ça c'est concordant avec
nos propres estimations à la Banque de
France euh où on fait aussi ce type ce
type d'évaluation alors évidemment le
régime de change a pu avoir des
conséquences aussi sur ce qu'on appelle
la compétitivité hors prix et on est
bien placé en France de savoir que avec
la même monnaie euh que nos voisins
allemands on n' pas du tout les mêmes
résultats en terme de commerce extérieur
donc la compétitivité hors prix euh ça a
aussi une importance et je voulais
signaler la sortie le 10 novembre
dernier d'une étude financée par l'AFD
et réalisée par la Ferdi sur la
compétitivité hors prix dans les pays de
l'UMOA qui regarde les différs facteurs
et notamment tous les facteurs liés à la
gouvernance au climat des affaires mais
aussi aux infrastructures et notamment
aux infrastructures
d'énergie sur les avantages
ou les inconvénients du système de
change donc il y a une littérature assez
abondante euh mais qui s'est un peu
épuisé au cours du temps euh je voulais
là aussi signaler une étude qui est
récemment sorti de lafferdi et qui
montre sur le long terme avec tous les
cavéades possibles à ce genre d'étude
que le système de change a été favorable
pour la stabilité monétaire ayant été
favorable pour la stabilité monétaire il
a été favorable pour la réduction de la
pauvreté parce que l'inflation euh
touche avant tous les pauvres et
notamment quand il y a des périodes
d'hyperinflation parce que l'accès aux
devises étrangères puisque la
conséquence des épisodes
d'hyperinflation c'est la dollarisation
des économies et l'accès au devises
étrangères est beaucoup plus difficile
pour les pauvres par contre et c'est
effectivement un peu décevant on ne décè
pas d'effet significatifs sur la
croissance ni dans un sens négatif ni
dans un sens positif dans cette étude de
long terme de lafferd alors il y a eu
une question sur est-ce que il y a eu
plusieurs interventions disant
que les pays de la coopération monétaire
devaient récupérer une monnaie dont ils
sont les seuls maîtres a priori
aujourd'hui ils sont les seuls maîtres
de leur monnaie simplement ils ont fait
un
premier don de souveraineté monétaire en
créant des unions monétaires donc ils
ont renoncé comme nous l'avons fait
nous-mêmes à leur souveraineté monétaire
au niveau des États et puis ils ont
chois is un système de change fixe qui
est un système effectivement qui
contraint beaucoup leur politique
monétaire mais qui est un système un
choix de change fixe qui n'est pas si
anormal pour les pays de niveau de
développement comparable et la plupart
des pays à faible revenu ont soit des
systèmes de change fixe soit des
systèmes de change fortement gérés pour
éviter la volatilité des taux de change
dans ce type d'économie donc l'idée
qu'il ne serait pas pas les seuls
maîtres de leur politique monétaire me
paraî une idée une idée fausse et donc
là j'en viens à la question qui a été
posée sur est-ce que la politique de
coopération monétaire peut enrayer la
propagande antif-française elle l'a
plutôt
entretenu et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a fait la réforme de la
coopération monétaire annu MOA et que on
fera la réforme de la coopération
monétaire en SMAC pour enlever un
certain nombre de symboles qui favoriser
les fausses interprétations mais il
reste bien sûr des fausses
interprétations euh l'idée par exemple
que c'est parce que les billets sont
fabriqués à la Banque de France que en
fait c'est la France qui contrôle
l'émissions monétaire est une idée
complètement fausse la plupart des paysh
euh d'Afrique subsaharienne imporent
leurs billets euh sur la base de
relations commerciales de la même façon
que la Banque de France a des relations
commerciale avec la BCEAO ou la Béac et
donc ils importent leur billets de
société commerciales et ils sont
fabriqués en Angleterre en Allemagne et
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec l'émission
monétaire un petit peu de la même
manière sur le stock d'or euh nous
détenons effectivement à la Banque de
France le stock d'or de la BCO comme
nous gérons euh les stocks d'or d'un
grand nombre de banques centrales
simplement parce que ça leur facilite
leurs opérations quand les stocks sont
détenus euh dans un certain nombre de
banques centrales qui F fournissent des
services notamment de prêt d'or ça leur
permet de valoriser leurs réserves et
d'utiliser ces réserves en stock d'or et
ça n'a rien à voir avec la main mise une
quelconque main mise de la Banque de
France
sur les stocks sur les stocks
d'or je voulais intervenir sur deux
choses en dehors
peut-être
des des problématiques liées à la
coopération monétaire Afrique France
la première c'était sur une question sur
la fuite des cerveaux donc là je voulais
signaler des travaux notamment du du
professeur ilel Rapoport qui montre que
il y a des effets positifs qui au cas
par cas dont il faut au cas par cas
tenir compte sur la fuite des cerveaux
d'abord parce que ça encourage une
diaspora qui est encore plus active dans
les relations avec les pays entre les
pays de dé part et les pays d'accueil ce
qui génère de la croissance il y a bien
sûr aussi la génération de remise de
travailleurs immigrés qui fournit aussi
des financements comme vous le savez
dans le monde les remises de
travailleurs immigrés ont dépassé
maintenant les volumes d'APD donc c'est
une source de financement importante on
en a pas parlé mais il y a aussi un
élément qu' faut pas oublier c'est que
la possibilité de partir à l'étranger
d'émigrer pour valoriser ses compétences
renforce l'attractivité de l'éducation
et notamment de l'éducation supérieure
dans un certain nombre de pays donc les
effets de la fuite des cerveaux sont pas
forcément tous négatifs il y en a des
positifs et au cas par cas il faut faire
la balance sur ces sur ces sur ces sur
ces
problématiques et puis il y a la
question effectivement de la
disproportion et qui me frappe aussi et
là je j'interviens plutôt en terme
personnel entre les besoins de
financement tels qu'ils sont annoncés et
calculés par les
diverses institutions internationales et
les flux officiels d'aide qu'on peut
mettre sur la table et ça ça un
caractère je trouve assez déprimant et
ça vient probablement du fait que il y a
peut-être mais c'est une réflexion
personnelle une surestimation des
besoins de
financement d'une part et d'autre part
ces besoins de financement qui sont
calculés pour atteindre les les
objectifs de développement durable sont
par nature très difficiles à calculer il
y a 17 objectifs de développement
durable un certain nombre de pays
africains sont très loin on est déjà en
retard et donc ça conduit peut-être à
une surévaluation des besoins de
financement tel que on les voit dans les
échanges dans les cercles internationaux
éval par les organisations
internationales merci Monsieur le
Directeur adjoint la parole est à
Monsieur William Ross de la DG trésor
merci beaucoup pour pour votre écoute
votre intérêt vos questions et et vos
commentaires sur la partie besoin de de
financement euh quand quand je veux
parler de légitimité c'était pas dans
dans un sens moral hein c'était dans le
sens de oui on on voit qu'il y a des des
besoins pour pour le le développement
économique des besoins pour l'action
climatique que ce soit sur la réduction
des émissions et surtout pour l'Afrique
sur l'adaptation au au changement
climatique euh il y a eu un un rapport
qui a été commandé par la présidence
indienne du du G20 à deux économistes un
Américain et un indien Larry Summers et
ncassing et ils se sont appuyés sur
d'autres études de qui avaient été
faites précédemment NOTAM
monsieur Stern et et Madame songue et
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur et
là c'est pas sur l'Afrique hein c'est
c'est l'ensemble des des besoins dans
les pays en développement il considèrent
et peut-être que c'est un peu surestimé
hein c'est possible mais ça donne un peu
un ordre de grandeur il considère que à
l'horizon 2030 il faut 3000 milliards de
plus à la fois pour les enjeux de
développement et et les enjeux de de
climat au sens très large ils disent
tout de suite de de tiers he 2000
milliards sur les 3000 milliards doivent
venir de financements
locaux ça veut dire de financement de de
d'institutions financières locales de
leur banque local de la mobilisation des
des recettes fiscal dans ces pays et ils
évaluent à 1 milliard ce qui doit venir
on va dire de
l'extérieur des pays des pays en
développement et ensuite c'est un peu à
l' hache mais c'est juste pour avoir un
ordre de grandeur il considère que sur
ce qui doit venir de l'extérieur il y a
500 milliards qui doit être de de la
official development hein
od flux de développement flux d'aide au
développement et puis 500 autres qui
sont de la mobilisation de la finance
privée on va dire des des pays riches
euh et à l'intérieur de des des premiers
500 milliards euh bah ça se traduit en
du bilatéral du multilatéral et c'est
pour ça qu'on a un gros agenda du G20
d'accroître les capacités de financement
des banques multilatérales de
développement euh en financement
concessionnel donc à des taux vraiment
très très bas ou à à à des taux bas mais
sans qu'il soit de de niveau
concessionnel et donc on donc voilà on
essae en tout cas de l'ensemble des des
pays du G20 des actionnaires des des
banques multilatérales de d'optimiser le
capital euh de ces banques pour pour que
les les financements s'accroissent on
est ouvert la position française est
d'être ouverte à une discussion sur des
augmentations de capital de ces banques
multilatérales c'est aussi une manière
de répondre à la question sur comment on
fait dans un contexte de hausse de taux
d'intérêt et ben c'est vrai que d'une
part bon bah ça ça ça crée des
contraintes il faut être encore plus
rigoureux sur ses finances publiques
mais de l'autre on peut accroître les
capacité de financement à bateau à
bateau d'intérêt et ça ça peut passer
par les les banques multilatérale parce
que il y a des gros effets de levier
quand on met 1 € de capital dans une
banque multilatérale elle peut délivrer
6 7 6 7 € de ça fait x 6 x 7 en capacité
de prêt donc ça nous permet d'avoir un
effet de levier important euh ça c'était
le le premier sujet euh le le deuxième
qui est un peu autour de notre aide
publi au développement il y avait
beaucoup de questions autour la première
question c'était le est-ce qu'on a la
bonne répartition entre les dons et les
prêts je dirais que c'est un discussion
une question qui est politique qui est
légitime et qui qui a lieu je crois à
chaque année lors de la présentation du
de la mission aide publique au
développement la réponse que je peux
donner à un niveau technique c'est que
je crois qu'il est il est important que
des des pays comme la France mais
d'autres continuent à à avoir un volet
d'aide en en prêt parce qu'il reste des
besoins qui se financent qui doivent se
financer financer comme cela que ce soit
des besoins d'infrastructure ou des
besoins de de de bouclage des budgétaire
en fait hein et et c'est important que
il n'y ait pas que le FMI que les
banques multilatérales qui fassent des
prêts et que il y ait un un effet
catalytique euh après c'est un un bon
dosage à trouver et euh quand on regarde
les statistiques la méthodologie hein de
l'OCDE on a euh sur nos 15 milliards de
d'aide au développement on en a on va
dire 12 13 en en don et puis TR en en
prêt quand quand on traduit ça en en
équivalent don donc après c'est un débat
politique hein sur sur où mettre le
curseur mais je crois que c'est très
important et ça rejoint un peu une
question qui est faut-il faire des
annulations systématiques de de de prêt
ma réponse technique c'est non parce que
si on sait d'avance que les prêts vont
être automatiquement annulés au bout de
quelques années la bonne réponse c'est
d'arrêter de faire des prêts et de faire
que des dons c'est une forme d'honnêteté
vis-à-vis de du Parlement donc je crois
que si on veut continuer à pouvoir faire
des prêts il faut que les
restructurations soient uniquement quand
c'est absolument nécessaire et on les
fait au au club dans dans le casadre du
secrétariat du club de Paris en en assum
une priorité qui est
de de d'avoir vis-à-vis des
contribuables qui ont qui ont financé ce
prêt d'avoir le retour le plus important
pour la France tout en respectant les
les les limites du du du pays en
capacité de de rembourser sa dette mais
on est quand on négocie des aujourd'hui
des restructurations de dett on le fait
pour des pays comme la Zambie l'Éthiopie
Ghana et cetera notre priorité c'est oui
on va réduire les les flux financiers on
va réduire le service de la dette mais
on va faire en sorte que tout le capital
soit remboursé et c'est très très rare
aujourd'hui qu'on ait des annulations en
en capital et donc après il y a la
question de quand on l'a fait et
notamment de manière massive dans dans
le cadre coordonné multilatéral he
l'initiative paypau très endetté est-ce
que c'était correct de le comptabiliser
en en aide publique au développement euh
il y a je pourrais faire une réponse
statistique oui puisque c'est c'est
comme ça que ça doit être comptabilisé
hein c'est y a une règle auocde de
comptabilisation de et après sur le fond
c'est un c'est comme un don une
annulation de dette c'est un don on peut
c'est un jeu d'écriture he le la
différence entre Ann annulation de dette
et Don on peut très bien faire le don et
puis nous le renvoie pour pour
rembourser avec donc pour moi c'est
c'est une annulation de dette c'est un
c'est un don et ça doit être
comptabilisé alors de manières c'est
logique de faire de de présenter
l'ensemble et de pouvoir distinguer
qu'est-ce qui est de l'annulation de
dett qu'est-ce qui est du don qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui est de l' du prêt
qu'on traduit du prêt très concessionnel
qu'on traduit en équivalent don donc il
faut être transparent et puis ensuite
qu'il y a un débat politique sur la
répartition mais sachez que la France
fait en sorte que lorsqu'on veut faire
des des prêts on fait des prêts
lorsqu'on veut faire des dons on fait
des dons mais on fait on préfère faire
des dons plutôt que des annulations de
des annulations de de dett euh euh il y
avait le contrôle de notre aide publique
au au développement c'est effectivement
un sujet majeur et vous avez mis
l'accent dessus lors de la loi de 2021
il faut que en en interne dans notre
discussion au niveau français on ait une
évaluation de de ce que l'on fait
lorsqu'on fait des des des prê de
politiques publiques des aides
budgétaires euh on est encore plus
redevable de s'assurer de la bonne
utilisation des fonds par ces pays et ce
que l'on fait la plupart du temps c'est
de s'associer à des programmes FMI quand
on est sur un un appui budgétaire à un
pays en difficulté c'est une manière de
nous assurer que et on arrête les aides
lorsque par exemple le le pays n'est
plus d'accord pour mettre en œuvre les
améliorations de la gouvernance
financière de la transparence le compte
unique du Trésor toutes ces procédures
là voilà c'est des on essaie en fait de
de de pousser les pays qui en ont besoin
à aller vers un appui FMI un appui de la
Banque mondiale et ça nous donne du
levier pour pas qu'on soit seul à à
porter des des messages d'amélioration
de de de la gouvernance de la
gouvernance financière je finirai juste
sur le sur le sujet de du
francecfa euh comme comme l'a dit Bruno
Cabriac ça a été une réforme de symbole
et donc mais les symboles ça compte
après dans les discussions politiques
entre notre Ministre et les ministres
des des finances d'Afrique centrale ou
d'Afrique de l'Ouest rien n'est à bout
et le message de notre président de la
République le message de notre ministre
a été nous sommes à l'écoute si les pay
si les les gouvernements de ces pays
souhaitent une évolution évidemment la
France accompagnera cette évolution donc
mais je ce qu'on constate c'est que dans
beaucoup de zones du Monde il y a un il
y a une demande de d'avoir un appui pour
réduire les risques de change hein c'est
là je parle pas Afrique centrale Afrique
de l'Ouest mais de manière générale il y
a beaucoup de demandes sur comment on
peut aider les pays à réduire un peu la
volatilité réduire les risques de change
d'une certaine manière la coopération
monétaire telle qu'on l'a mis en place
est une réponse possible c'est pas la
seule euh elle a un certain coût en
terme de risque pour pour la France et
il est logique politiquement que vous
l'évaluez mais c'est une des réponses
possibles et ça peut expliquer pourquoi
il y a une recherche de d'une manière ou
d'une autre par souvent d'un appui
externe pour avoir ou une coopération
régionale pour avoir pour réduire les la
volatilité du du
change merci beaucoup pour cette
intervention et enfin la parole est à
Monsieur Jacques
ma merci monsieur le Président je vais
essayer de de regouper les questions qui
ont été qui ont été
posées la première c'est c'est une une
une remarque que je fais à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est que vous disposez
probablement du meilleur rapport sur la
coopération française qui a été fait
depuis une dizaine d'années ça fait 50
ans que je m'occupe de ces questions
donc j'ai un peu de recul c'est le
rapport Berville et qui a débouché sur
un texte de loi le 4 août 4 août euh
2021 que vous avez adopté je crois sans
votes contre et qui est un texte qui a
été travaillé avec l'ensemble des
acteurs
euh notamment de la société civile les
collectivités locales et cetera qui a
été travaillé pendant 3 ans donc vous
disposer d'un document remarquable je
regrette d'ailleurs mais c'est je me
permets de de dire ça que dans le le
rapport
Tabarot Bruno fou il soit à peine cité
alors c'est certainement un document de
référence malheureusement il est
largement mis remis en cause et là je
parle en tant que que citoyen par les
décisions du suicide de juillet dernier
qui remet en avant qui met en cause un
certain nombre de principes de base
notamment en matière de déliments de
l'aide donc cette question du contrôle
de la est largement et de
l'efficacité de la est largement
traité dans ce dans ce document et à
cette occasion lors d'audition je me
suis permis d'expliquer j'ai été
directeur du développement et de la
coopération dans l'ancien ministère de
la Coopération et j'ai été le premier
dans le ministère des Affaires
étrangères pour dire que il est très
difficile de voler de l'argent de la
française le système de contrôle
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui jusqu'au
dernierers
centimes pour s'assurer que de la qui
transite par des collectivités locales
des ONG et ceterain ne sert pas à des
opérations de blanchiment ou à des
financements de terroristes est
extrêmement ver jusqu'au dernier
bénéficiaire ce qui d'ailleurs
techniquement est très difficile à
mettre en œuvre vous imaginez bien dans
des pays où il y a pas d'état civil
enfin et cetera et cetera mais enfin on
est soumis à des audits permanents sur
nos sur nos opérations donc il est très
difficile que ça soit sur du prêt ou sur
du don j'ai dit très difficile j'ai pas
dit impossible mais impossible nul n'est
tenu de détourner de l'argent public
maintenant la question fondamentale est
de savoir si la destination de cet
argent et la plus optimale en terme de
de besoin à cet égard je voudrais juste
dire une deuxième chose c'est
que le portefeuille des projets parce
qu'on parle d'annulation de la dette on
parle d'augmentation des ressources mais
encore faut-il savoir à quoi les les
Destinées le portefeuille de projet
c'est euh sur un portefeuille il y a 90
% des projets que nous avons en
portefeuille qui ne sont pas financés et
très souvent c'est pas une question de
financement c'est une une question de
capacité de mise en œuvre le cas le plus
spectaculaire le plus connu qui est qui
est fréquemment cité c'est celui du
Grand Dinga le barrage à l'emboussure à
l'emboussure du Congo en territoire des
République démocratique du Congo dont on
parle depuis depuis 20 ans dont la
puissance c'est deux fois le plus grand
barrage chinois et et attend attend
encore une capacité de mise en œuvre
pour pouvoir assurer pratiquement rempir
pratiquement les besoins sur la moitié
du continent africain c'est un exemple
parmi beaucoup d'autres nous avons en
disponible un paquet de projets
notamment dans le domaine des
infrastructures qui ne trouveve pas non
pas un financement qui s'il y avait une
véritable capacité de mise en œuvre et
une démonstration de la pertinence du
projet trouverait trouverait un
financement que celui-ci soit public ou
privé deè deè chose je n'ai pas employé
le mot de culpabilité de d vis-à-vis de
qui que ce soit c'est ça fait pas partie
de mon vocabulaire j'ai été diplommate
donc je m'interdirais bien d'employer ce
mAb je pourrais dire plus précisément
qu'il y a des problèmes de
responsabilité croisée et de solidarité
à l'échelle planétaire en ce qui
concerne et je metens en évidence un
continent qui ne produit pas de CO2 mais
qui en revanche a des capacités de
captation de CO2 très importante et que
c'est un service environnemental et dans
la logique économique ce service environ
environnemental de trouver un
financement c'est tout ce que je dis je
dis je dis pas je dis pas
davantage quel qu'il soit
euh sur le contrôle de la je je
pourrais déboucher sur un sujet qui qui
tient à cœur visiblement certains
d'entre vous j'en suis ravi c'est de
renforcer la capacité en particulier des
ambassades dans le contrôle de la qui
transite par l'Agence française de
développement c'est un sujet ça fait un
demi-sècle qu'on parle de la tutelle de
la FD fa c'est récurrent et de son
émancipation notamment vis-à-vis d'un
d'une de ces deux tutelles qui est le
ministère des Affaires étrangères mais
localement localement et je suis bien
placé pour le dire la la capacité de
l'ambassade à pouvoir gérer l'ensemble
des partenariats français y compris
privé par le truchement des chambres de
commerce et cetera et est un vrai sujet
et il est sûr que la mise en cause du
statut
d'ambassadeur par le gouvernement est un
handicap terrible lorsque l'on on sait
que pour travailler dans certains pays
africains il faut un apprentissage long
qui passe par tout un circuit et qui
vous amène 15 ans après à être en mesure
de pouvoir appréhender les réalités
anthropologiques sociologiques politiqu
linguistique d'un pays et c'est pas en
étant parachuté que vous pourrez faire
ce métier dans de bonnes conditions et
surtout servir au mieux au mieux au
mieux la France
euh alors juste un je je profitais de de
cette audience de 3 minutes pour dire
une chose j'étais très proche de la
situation au Niger pour toute une série
de raisons et ce qui m'a paraît
extrêmement grave dans la situation de
nigère qui a connu un coup d'é terard
comme vous le savez au début du mois de
juillet et que nous avons géré je ne
discuterai pas de la manière dont ça a
été géré puisque le rapport fou l'évoque
mais je dirais que on n'a pas parlé des
Nigériens des 25 millions de Nigériens
qui du jour au lendemain sont trouvés
sous sanction de la CDAO indirectement
appuyé par la France pas de médicament
pas de produits vivriers pu d'essence pu
d'énergie simultanément la France a
décidé d'arrêter son APD ça veut dire
que nous préside un réseau de 17 ONG
français nous avons été obligé de
suspendre nous avons licencié plus de 50
personnes
nigérien nous avons suspendu tous nos
programmes en direction de la mère et de
l'enfant de la lutte contre la
malnutrition l'insertion des jeunes la
promotion de
l'agroécologie des dizaines et dizaines
de projets en direction des populations
les plus vulnérables nous avons dit la
France arrête de vous aider vous
imaginez comment ça contribue au
ressentiment antirançais ces deux
mesures si vous ajoutez à ça troisème
pénalité que la jinte au pouvoir se
détourne de sa mission de sécurité de
lutte contre les groupes armés pour se
redistribuer les prébandes après avoir
évincé un certain nombre de politique
d'un certain nombre d'entreprises
publiques de et cetera et cetera on est
dans une situation dramatique et là je
parle en tant que citoyen français et en
sain diplomate je trouve que cette
attitude est absolument contreproductive
dans l'image que nous avons alors que on
avait un moyen on a fait cette erreur
dans le passé on l'a fait au Togo on l'a
fait en République démocratique du Congo
ex on continue de le faire sur le Mali
sur le Burkina Faso sur le
Niger alors qu'on essaie de réfléchir
sur notre image là on dégrade
terriblement tout comme la politique des
visas mais je crois que ça a été dit
largement je n revient pas enfin je vais
me permettre bien que ce soit pas du
domaine de ma compétence exacte mais
ayant été au conseil d'administration de
la bsao pendant un certain nombre
d'années juste un petit mot sur le le
Fran FAA tout ce qui a été dit est
parfaitement vrai ce qui était le
problème c'est que ça reste un élément
de fantasme important euh le billet de
banque qui est fabriqué à chemalière et
qui s'appelle le franc hein euh pour la
zone semmac le fait que que 50 % des
dépôts en dev sont en France tout ça ça
ça alimente un fantasme aujourd'hui ce
qu'il est sûr c'est qu'il y a euh
clairement on sait on doit aller en tout
cas avec un certain nombre d'experts
africains on travaille sur ces questions
depuis pas mal de temps on sait qu'il
faut sortir du rattachement à l'euro
parce qu'il y a pas eu de logique à se à
à vivre à à comment dirais-je àir comme
retomberé sur la situation monétaire des
pays africains les les rapports que
l'euro entretient avec les rapports
commerciaux que les pays membres de
l'Europe on ent y a quelque chose
d'incohérent si vous voulez donc
évidemment un ratement sur un panier de
devis représentative des des des
activités des réseaux commerciaux des
activités commerciales de la zone me
paraît absolument
évident probablement une certaine marche
de flexibilité c'est ce qu'on appelle
déclaration de l'omé une marche de
flexibilité tout comme ça existe dans
certains pays le le la référence a été
faite au Maroc par exemple donc on a on
a un certain nombre de un certain nombre
d'éléments notre le dans la réflexion il
y a deux choses qui n'ont pas été évoqué
par mes par mes collègues qui ont dit
beaucoup de choses importante c'est un
est-ce que le CFA tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui la parité n'est pas une
prime aux importations si c'est une
prime aux importations on a un sérieux
problème pour pouvoir monter des
politiques de souveraineté
alimentaire si le riz arrive les brisurs
de riz arrivent à des prix à des prix
desfiantes concurrence la les le lait le
lait arrive dans les mêmes conditions
les les ailes de d'ind d'arriver dans
les même condition on a beaucoup de mal
à mettre en place une une véritable
souveraineté alimentaire l'autre
question qui n'a pas été évoquée c'est
le crédit à l'économie j'ai fini sur le
crédit à l'économie est-ce que le
système tel qu'il existe encore est
favor
favorise le crédit à l'économie dans les
pays concernés ce n'est pas ça n'est pas
certain voilà quelques quelques remarqu
que je voulais faire en vous remerciant
d'avoir posé ces
questions bien bien écoutez merci à tous
pour cette audition très intéressante
qui montre bien le lien entre les enjeux
financiers et les enjeux de de sécurité
c'est pourquoi en tant commissaire à la
défense il était important d'avoir un
regard même lointain sur ces enjeux
financiers afin de réfléchir aux
meilleures voies pour contribuer à la
sécurisation de nos pays partenaires et
bien entendu on compte sur vous
également commissaire aux finances pour
continuer à vous investir également à
votre manière sur les sujets de de
défense et on se tient à votre
disposition voilà merci à tous pour
cette audition et la parole est à mon
co-président Éric
ocrel ah
pardon avec les commissaires aux finance
pas parce que j'ai un petit point alors
alors qu'il aurait précis pour eux juste
merci je pense que c'était passionnant
donc moi je suis disponible avec la
commission pour qu'on renouvelle cette
expérience sur des sujets croisés
finance défense et
internationale juste pour la commission
des finances donc là ça concerne
uniquement les commissaires aux finances
il convient que nous demions rapporteur
sur la proposition de loi numéro 1798
visant à baisser le prix des billets de
train express régionaux par une
fiscalité allégée dont nous serons
saisis la semaine prochaine je suis
saisi de la candidature de Monsieur
Antoine Vermorel marquez qui était là
tout à l'heure il n'y a pas d'opposition
il en est ainsi décidé pas d'opposition
ça sera le cas et je rappelle que les
membres du bureau de la commission des
finances se retrouve tout de suite en
commission des finances merci